[Musique]
Jean-Luc badec bonjour ça va ça va bien
Patrice ça va très bien c'est chronique
d'autant mieux voilà c'est chronique
c'est vous hein de bonne santé d'autant
que là on va parler de quelqu'un pour
qui bah la vie est belle puisque c'est
un grand gastronome c'est kurnski alors
oui c'est Maurice Edmond saillant ça
c'est son vrai nom ah oui
Maum le prince des gastronomes c'est
comme ça qu'il est surnommé et
effectivement euh son nom d'artiste
allez on peut dire ça comme ça c'est
kurnovski pourquoi bien parce que à
l'époque où vit
kururnonski c'est très à la mode d'avoir
un nom à consonance russe c'est la
pleine période des nobles originaires de
Russie qui arrive en France et ça fait
très bien d'avoir son nom finissante en
ski alors voilà pourquoi mauis monsayon
s'appelle qui est connu aujourd'hui bien
sûr sous ce noml c'est quelle époque
alors c'est la fin du 19e siècle et le
début du 20e siècle mais ça va quand
même jusque
1935 c'est d'ailleurs une fin terrible
parce qu' il il il chute de sa fenêtre
triste fin mais pour un homme qui a
formidablement vécu et qui a été
probablement un de ceux qui ass C
période ont le plus promu la gastronomie
française mais il n'était pas seulement
gastronome il était également quelqu'un
qui savait mettre en lumière les grands
cuisiniers les grandes tables de
l'époque et alors ce qui est tout un peu
l'ancêtre de Gobillot de ça Michelin
c'est d'autant plus l'en de Michelin mon
cher Patrice que figurez-vous que c'est
lui kurnnovski alors qu'il a également
des fonctions de publicitaire on est à à
l'origine de la publicité c'est lui qui
a dessiné et inventé le bibindom c'est
pas vrai pour bifla ah c'est formidable
anecdote ah bah oui ben alors ça rejoint
alors on rejoint un peu ce qu'on dit
c'està dire que à la fois voilà c'est
c'est l'ancêtre de tous les chroniqueurs
gastronomiques il a développé une
nouvelle façon de voir la gastronomie et
la restauration dans notre pays c'est un
personnage truculant exceptionnel et qui
a laissé évidemment des traces très
profondes don on parle aujourd'hui ABS
pouri le prince des gastron et bien
précisément parce que à l'époque il y a
bien entendu euh quelques restaurants de
renommé mais pas tant que ça le
transport commence à se développer et
évidemment à travers le développement du
transport se sont également développés
les belelles obbergesant les auerges
voilà et ce prince des gastronomes est
considéré comme quelqu'un qui a apporté
la modernité dans la façon d'appréhender
le repas déjà déjà he c'est à chaque
fois un peu plus de modernité voilà et
c'est formidable et là je crois que
voilà il faut dire aux gens si vous
descendez maintenant dans dans dans
auberges si vous vous DZ au restaurant
ayez une pensée pour pour ce knonski
quand même qui s'appelait
monsieurant Mace Edmond saant merci
beaucoup à bientôt Patrice à
[Musique]
bientôt